- [Voiceover] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(peaceful music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of
the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Laura d'Andrea Tyson
who is professor of business
administration and economics
and director of the Institute for Business
and Social Impact at the
Haas School of Business.
She is a former chairman of the
Council of Economic Advisors
in the Clinton administration.
Laura served as dean of the Haas School
and of the London Business School.
Professor Tyson is the 2015
Harvest Distinguished Lecturer.
This is a series which features women
from a broad range of
disciplines and cultures.
It offers a forum to
foster thoughtful dialogue
and an opportunity to be inspired
by outstanding and accomplished
real world women leaders.
Laura, welcome back to our program.
- Thank you, Harry.
- [Harry] What attracted you to economics?
- You know, I discovered economics.
I was pretty good at math at high school.
I went to college thinking I'd do math,
which is pretty rare
for a girl at the time.
And I went to a woman's college.
Took a class in economics
and instantly realized
that's what I wanted to do.
Because I wanted to do
something that was rigorous
where I could use analysis and math.
But that addressed policy problems.
'Cause I actually had always been
interested in those, as well.
Even in high school.
So, it was a wonderful combination.
- And, looking back,
what factors in your life
influenced your commitment
to progressive values?
Which is, I think, a fair assessment
of where you fall on the spectrum.
- Yes, and I'm not entirely
sure I can link, trace it.
I mean, part of it, I suppose, is that
my parents were raised poor
in Jersey City and Bayonne.
My father was...
His life was very much
shaped by the GI Bill.
So, they're rising into the middle class.
He's the first person in his family,
extended Italian family, to go to college.
Emphasis on education
from the very beginning.
I suspect the nuns in Catholic school
may have a little to do
with my progressive values.
Taking care of the disadvantaged
and paying attention to equity concerns
and the concerns of
others clearly, I think,
was something you got in Catholic school.
And then I gradually,
as I went to college,
began to study history and
study political science.
And realized that the values that I had
were what I guess we call
now progressive values.
Maybe we call them liberal values.
I don't know.
- And has it been difficult to reconcile
the discipline, essentially
what the numbers say,
if I can make a short
version of economics,
and where the values lead?
I mean, in other words...
Or is that really about
defining the problems
you wanna look at?
- So, my colleague at the
Council of Economic Advisors
who was also a classmate of
mine at MIT, Alan Blinder,
wrote a very good book about 25 years ago.
Maybe 30 years ago.
And he's actually in the
process of revising it.
It's called Hard Heads, Soft Hearts.
And basically he says,
"Economists have hard heads.
They wanna figure out the
best way to do something.
The most efficient way to do something.
The least costly way to do something.
But they can certainly have soft hearts."
That is, what's the best way to provide
early childhood education
for disadvantaged families?
What's the best way to provide
employment opportunities
for high school dropouts?
So, you can be committed to the values
and then say what's the best way?
So, I think there's a natural combination.
- And the interface must be important,
because the economics must bring rigor
to where your heart wants to go.
- So, I think that's
the hard head concept.
These things are not...
Doing these things are very difficult.
Some ways are more effective than others.
Some ways don't work at all.
Some things that sound good,
it turns out, when you
actually look at the evidence,
don't really work.
So, you have to say I'm
committed to my values.
I'm committed to my goal.
I want to do this.
Let me look analytically about
the best ways to achieve this.
And I think that's what
the rigor of the discipline
forces you to do.
- Now, what about the leap from
economics to public policy?
'Cause there's an interface
there that's challenging.
- [Laura] Yes, yes.
- Talk a little about the
adaption that has to take place,
if that's the right word.
- You know, Berkeley
was very important to me
in terms of my preparation
for a role in public policy.
With some of my colleagues at the time,
we got interested in US economic
competitiveness and trade.
We started something that you know about
called the Berkeley Round Table
on the International Economy.
We started to deal with policy
makers and business leaders.
Trying to give advice about
how to make the US more competitive,
how to raise productivity,
what a trade agreement should look like.
So, gradually, slowly,
over a decade, I would say,
I started to have those
kinds of interactions.
I was not like many of my colleagues
in the Clinton
administration who had spent
most of their life in politics
aiming to be a policy
maker at the highest level.
I had really spent my
life in academic circles,
but in advisory capacities.
On commissions, things like that.
Writing commission reports.
So, it was really surprise
and a great stroke of luck, really,
that I ended up in the
position that I ended up in.
I mean, my work was known.
It was known to the
President-Elect Bill Clinton.
He knew about my academic work.
But I still was thrown into an environment
where I didn't quite know all the rules.
I said then, and I think it's true,
that being an economist,
but being an economist who
could explain things clearly
to large groups of...
To 900 sophomores and
freshmen at Berkeley.
If I could explain economics to them,
I should be able to
explain it to the public,
to policy makers, to members of Congress.
So, I was viewed as someone
who could be very articulate
and helpful in both designing policy,
but also explaining it and
making people understand
why this was the right thing to do.
Came from my academic, my
life at Berkeley, I must say.
- At this point, I like to ask my guests
about what they see is
the skills and temperament
involved in the discipline.
So, in your case, what
do you see as important,
in that regard, with regard to economics,
but also public policy?
- So, for economics, I
would say I clearly have...
I guess I would say I suggest I have
a fairly analytical
approach to problem solving.
Somehow or other, I was born with that.
It got nurtured over time.
That's really important.
I think I've been open in economics
to different ways of thinking.
So, I did a lot of work in
comparative economics at one point.
I have a general view of skepticism.
Like we don't know the
answers and no model is right,
but we can get better.
I used to say that served
me well in public policy,
because a lot of people
feel like "Here's the answer
and I'm gonna do everything I can
to get straight to the answer.
Because I believe in my answer.
And, frankly, I don't
believe in any compromises."
That's not gonna work.
So, my view is, "Okay, you
kinda know where you wanna go
and you may have to kind
of go slowly with zig zags.
As long as you're not going backwards.
You're going forwards."
But willingness to kind
of see room for compromise
or room for going slowly,
seeing a different perspective.
I think I temperamentally have that.
And that's actually been really important
in both economics and in public policy.
I mean, finally, I
apparently have the ability
to take complex things
and make them simple.
And, actually, people said that,
when I would do an
economics paper or lecture
to what I would do in
public policy session
to when I would do a lecture for students.
So, I think that is a skill.
Because, if you're
explaining complex concepts
and complicated solutions to people
who are not trained in your discipline,
then you are trying to bring them along
to see an outcome which you
believe is the best outcome.
But, you know, we live in a democracy.
We live in a situation where
you don't impose your views.
You convince people of your views.
- That view is atypical, isn't it?
Because, in the disciplines,
it's really about talking
to your colleagues.
Is that fair?
- Well, I don't think
I was very traditional
in that respect.
I really don't.
I think that I...
- No, I'm noting that.
- No, no, no, I would say,
in the first decade of
my professional life
as an academic economist,
I did the right things.
I wrote papers for my specialty.
I went to conferences for my specialty.
I taught classes in my specialty.
Very complicated PhD classes.
I did that.
It was interesting to me.
But I really felt it was too constraining.
Too restrictive.
So, it gradually...
It didn't happen overnight.
I started to say, "No, the
things that actually interest me
from a point of view of my own sighting
which I live in making things better
are a different set of issues.
And a different set of people
are having this conversation.
Not my academic colleagues."
So, I would say there
was a period of time...
And, again, I would say it's kind of like
a decade long process.
When I, at Berkeley, found
similarly inclined colleagues.
Berkeley has a wonderful tradition
of allowing people to work
across disciplinary lines,
if they want.
And that's really what I started to do.
In fact, I started to co-teach a class
with a political scientist.
Pretty rare.
I started to do a little more teaching
in the business school and out
of my economics discipline,
because business school curricula
is more related to public
policy or application problems.
So, I gradually made this transition.
- And you're saying that
communication skills
and writing skills have
been very important to you.
Where did you learn to write well?
- Well, I don't know.
I decided, again, in the early 1980s...
I date all of this pretty well,
because this was a period of time where
I was teaching very large
econ one classes at Berkeley,
when my son was born,
and when the Berkeley Round
Table was being formed.
So, all of these things were signs
of real change in my own life.
And what I wanted to do at the time,
I thought, "You know, I'm clearly...
I'm involved in writing
these commission reports.
I'm involved in going to conferences.
I really should try to write something
of an opinion column sort
to get my thoughts out to the
public in a different way."
And so, I started to do that.
I've done it over the decades since
for the LA Times and Business
Week and the New York Times
and the Financial Times.
And I'm currently doing something for
a blog site called Project Syndicate,
which has economists
and political scientists
from all over the world.
And they place them in
newspapers all over the world.
So, I would not say that
writing is easy for me, however, Harry.
I think it's actually hard for me.
And I spend a lot of time
on each of my columns.
Probably much...
I could not be a columnist.
If I were a columnist
and I had to write something every day,
I'm not sure I could get
out of the house any day.
So, I think that I'm clear in my writing
and I think that I rely a
lot on facts and analysis.
My columns tend to be
analytical and fact-based,
rather than just opinion.
I think it's important.
I think it's important to do.
I don't actually really enjoy doing them.
(laughter)
A confession.
- I've read many of them.
You're doing a very good
job of informing people
and helping people who don't
have an economics background
to understand.
Talk a little about Washington.
What surprised you most
when you went to Washington?
- Well, first of all,
a couple of things come to mind, I guess.
First of all, when I first
started to testify in Congress,
which I had to do in my role as
the chair of the Council
of Economic Advisors,
what I thought was, "Well, I can go
and use evidence and logic
and my skills as an economist
to convince this committee that
what we're doing in the Clinton
administration is correct."
And, after going many times
and realizing that that was not happening,
I did realize what people said to me.
"No, no, this is a kind
of political theater.
You go and make your statement.
You have to do this.
Everyone else makes their statement.
There's very little
real exchange of ideas."
The exchange of ideas probably
goes on behind the scenes
with the staff.
So, there's very, very
talented young people
who staff the senators
and House of Representative congressmen
and all of the committees.
And they are doing real work.
But the hearings
themselves where I would go
into a lecture situation historically
and feel like, "Oh, I can convince people.
I can educate people.
I'm imparting real information here.
It's not a performance."
I felt that a lot of what I
ended up doing on the Hill
was a bit of performance art.
That was a surprise.
I also figured out...
And this was a little related
to the issue of gender.
When I first got to the White House,
I had a very high level position.
But, even in the White House,
you have a high level position,
that doesn't necessarily mean that
you're gonna be invited
to the right meetings.
It doesn't.
So, at a certain point,
I started to feel like
the Council of Economic Advisors
should be in this meeting.
So, I need to go and make a
request to be in the meeting.
And that was very hard for me.
But I did it.
I represented my institution.
We're economists.
We must be at this meeting.
And I was told at the
time "That's fine, Laura.
You don't realize how
many men have come in here
and asked for that.
And they get it.
And you took a while to do it,
but you realized that
you needed to do it."
So, that was like, well,
that's a rule I didn't know.
An unwritten rule, whoa.
So, I got better at saying,
"Okay, who should be in the room?
We should be in the room."
And then making a point
of being in the room.
And I didn't get any pushback.
But it's sort of like you have to do that.
You have to take the first step.
So, a lot of the evidence about
women in large organizations
is women don't negotiate for positions.
They don't go in and say,
"Hey, I would be great for that job.
Think of me."
They hold back a little bit
and wait to be discovered.
That doesn't work in politics.
It doesn't work in organizations, either.
- Looking back at your time
in the Clinton administration,
and we know about the events that occurred
after you all had been out
of office for many years...
I'm talking about the
economic crisis of 2008.
As you reflect back, do you
have any reflections or thoughts
about what things that might
have been done differently?
- I think the first term...
And I was only there for the first term.
And it's important in terms
of telling that story, also,
to note on the side, as I
said in the Harvest Lecture.
After four years in government,
I certainly wanted to stay.
But, from the family's point
of view, husband and son,
they didn't wanna stay.
And the job was a family job.
It wasn't an individual job.
The whole family had the job.
They had it in different forms.
But they had the job.
- But, by that, you mean that
the job was taking so much of your time.
- So much of my time that everything else
that had to do with the work of the family
was secondary to me and imposed on them.
And it was enough.
It was really enough.
There were several men,
including my good friend
Bob Reich and his family,
who left at the same
time for the same reason.
So, I felt that the budget
plan was the right thing to do.
And it turned out to be very important
from the point of view
of being the first step
to getting us on the road to
a sustainable fiscal course.
There was a second step in the
beginning of the second term,
but they were linked.
They were absolutely linked.
I think that the North
American Free Trade Agreement
and then the completion
of the Uruguay Round,
I think, were very important.
I know they're controversial
among the Democrats.
But I think the evidence, from
the economic point of view,
is positive.
I regret...
I think we all regret that
we were not able to
move healthcare forward.
I think we don't...
The Clinton administration
doesn't regret...
And I was actually a skeptic
of the welfare reform.
I literally was a skeptic.
I have a note from the president saying,
"Thank you for your counsel.
I understand your concerns.
But this is what we're going to do."
He was right.
So, I don't...
But healthcare probably was obviously
the biggest sort of lost opportunity.
The second term, however, I wasn't there.
I thing the biggest lost
opportunity, by far,
was social security reform.
Because, as you began to see
those surpluses building up,
it was pretty clear that
there were two things
that might happen.
There would either be a tax cut,
which is what George W. Bush
decided to do with that money,
or there would be a social security reform
that would essentially use
that money for social security.
And the second term
Clinton administration,
it was not possible, in a
way, to move in that direction
because of all of the
other things going on
around the presidency at that time.
And I think, from an
economic point of view,
that's a tremendous loss.
- In the second term, did
the administration go too far
in terms of deregulation?
- It's possible that, at the...
It was towards the very end.
I think that...
It was a moment in time when
the economy was doing so well.
Productivity was so high.
There was a kind of love of technology.
Technology was transforming
the retail sector,
the wholesale sector, but
also the financial sector.
The financial sector's ability to develop
intricate new products,
financial engineering,
risk management, that
was all just exploding.
Frankly, no one really
completely understood it.
I remember I had Alan Greenspan
come to the Haas School
when I first became dean in 1998.
And he actually said to me,
"It's like having a really fancy new car.
You open up the hood and you
don't know what's going on."
That's Alan Greenspan.
Okay, so, that was the situation.
And there was a kind of
sense in my profession,
among financial experts, that
the system is going to...
One of the things it can do, in a way,
we don't quite understand
is manage risk better.
But, of course, my view,
even at the time...
I wrote a piece about
this in Business Week.
I said, "Why does one think that?
Maybe it just moves the risk around
in ways that we can't see.
And actually makes the risk bigger,
because, if everybody
thinks the risk is smaller,
they're gonna take riskier actions."
It's almost like it's self-fulfilling.
If I believe the system is less risky,
hey, I can personally be pretty risky.
So, there was...
The administration was
certainly not alone in its view
that the financial markets were becoming
so sophisticated that they
could regulate themselves
in ways which we didn't quite understand.
That turned out to be wrong.
- It's interesting.
Because you were influential,
having been in the administration.
You wrote a piece.
Why were the majority of
powerful people in Washington
not listening to you?
Which is not to say you were
the only one saying that.
Is it just the herd instinct?
- I think that that was not
the conventional wisdom,
the herd instinct, the
dominant paradigm at the time.
As reflected in having
Bob Rubin, Larry Summers,
and Alan Greenspan on the
cover, I guess it was of Time.
Master of the Universe.
The dominant view of the time was
"Boy, financial markets
have become more stable.
We're more sophisticated.
There's more ways for the
system to manage risk.
Therefore, we don't need
to do as much regulation."
There was another point of view
at the same time out there,
which is US financial institutions
are competing globally.
They need to compete globally.
We don't want to restrict them
in ways which disadvantage them
in this global competition.
So, there was another thing going on.
So, occasionally, voices
would be raised of concern,
but it really was not the
dominant view at the time.
- Now you are an observer.
- [Laura] You learn from your mistakes.
- Hopefully.
- I think a lot has been learned.
I recently did a book...
The last interview with Timothy
Geithner on his book tour.
And I just said to the audience,
"There is so much in this book
which really reflects what has been done,
which is very significant, and, of course,
also indicates some of the things that
still need to be done."
For example, we have not, in any way,
in the United States, dealt
with the housing market.
We have...
Most of the mortgages are coming
through Fannie and Freddie.
Government institutions.
We don't have that part of the
financial market worked out.
We've put it on hold.
We've put it on hold while we
sort of did some other things.
- You're an observer now here at Haas.
And I wanna ask you, comparing
the Clinton presidency
and the Obama presidency,
what do you see, how has
the environment changed?
Has it changed drastically?
Or is it just more of the same
old stuff in extreme form?
- Well, I think you have to
ask that question in two ways.
One is internally and one is
with the rest of the world.
So, internally, I think you could say
these are extreme versions of tendencies
that were already obvious in
the Clinton administration.
So, if we go back to the
budget plan in the first term,
there were no Republicans
who supported that.
And, indeed, they said
from the very beginning
in January of the first year
of President Clinton's first term.
They said, "We will not
support your program."
I mean, so it wasn't like there was
any possibility to compromise.
We will not support your program.
You're gonna have to get enough Democrats
to get this through.
We're not gonna do it.
That was very similar to what Obama heard
in the beginning of his first term.
It was much worse for him,
because he had a huge financial crisis.
An economic crisis,
threatening crisis right there
happening in real time.
It turns out, in the
Clinton administration,
things were starting to get better.
They had started to get better.
So, the magnitude of the
problem was less severe.
But, also, the nasty partisan
unwillingness to compromise,
unwillingness to come up
with a bipartisan plan,
which you'd seen in
the first term of the
Clinton administration,
you certainly saw in the
Obama administration.
By the way, the second term
of the Clinton administration
was better because that budget deal
in the beginning of the second term
did get bipartisan support.
So, after government shutdown...
Remember the first government shutdown
was under the first term of
the Clinton administration.
I was there.
That technique, that
tactic of getting one's way
was not used again until
the Obama administration.
And there's even a threat, apparently,
that it will be used again
at the end of this year.
So, unwillingness to compromise
is something that has gotten worse,
because, first, the far right has gained
a very significant hold
over the members of Congress
in the Republican Party.
Making it extremely difficult for
Boehner and McConnell to
really move their party
to any compromise position.
They can barely get their party to agree
on their own position.
Much less a compromise position.
And that just means that
there's not the ability...
Who's your partner in trying
to work out a compromise?
Who's your partner?
On the external side, I will just say that
the US, we have, when Obama took office,
the US was extremely
unpopular in the world.
The unilateral coalition
of the willing approach
had completely broken down.
And, I think, the need to follow
what has been a traditional
democratic instinct,
which is use multilateral institutions
and agreements with allies that
are worked out at the beginning
to get something done,
that's a different
approach to foreign policy.
A different approach to foreign policy.
- In the context of these
changes in the political system,
as someone who's on the progressive side,
what do you then see is
the role of government?
What is possible in such an environment?
- So, a couple of things
are interesting here.
I think you saw some of
this in the last election.
Although the country
significantly swung to the right
or appeared to in who they elected,
if you actually looked at what
people thought about things,
like the minimum wage or social security
or early childhood education
or equity in educational opportunities,
most people support those things.
Actually are ardent
supporters of those things.
Okay, so, the kind of progressive values,
as reflected in things people care about,
are still very present
among American voters.
So, but the people that are
being elected into Congress
are not as reflective.
Now, that's partly to
do with gerrymandering
and the way elections are
run in the United States.
The role of money and the
role of gerrymandering.
So, the people who are elected
don't necessarily reflect
these views at all.
It's something else going on.
And then I would say another
thing that is true is that,
at state and local government levels,
some really interesting
things are going on
in some rather red states.
So, Utah's doing some
really interesting things
in early childhood education.
Tennessee is doing amazing
things in community college.
Kentucky is doing amazing
things in healthcare.
Using, working with Obamacare to achieve
dramatic improvements in healthcare.
So, let's say, for a while,
for reasons of money in politics
and gerrymandering and who
wants to run for office
at the level of Congress
in the United States,
Congress is the, I would say,
the broken organization of government.
And I would say that we're seeing
a lot of signs at the state
and local levels that...
Not all states.
I mean, clearly, there
are some states that
are absolutely walking away from
the kinds of social policy
we're talking about.
But lots of states, including
ones you wouldn't predict,
are embracing it.
And why are they doing that?
Because that's what
their populations want.
So, what happens at the federal level?
You know, I guess a
disappointment to me was,
if you think about the
rise of the Tea Party,
the rise of the Tea Party was
a bunch of disgruntled
voters who got together
and formed a political organization
and then influenced electoral outcomes.
What did the 99% do?
Didn't do any of that.
They protested.
They wrote some things.
And they dissipated.
No effort to run candidates,
to influence elections,
to come up with a policy.
Sooner or later, the only
way to change Washington
is to change who goes there.
That's the only way to do it.
And you have to be politically
mobilized to do that.
- In one of your columns, you argued about
the possibilities of perceiving government
as almost like a venture capitalist.
And that follows from what you just said.
Talk a little about that.
- So, one of the unremarked
innovations, I would say,
in the Obama administration...
And I think this will just grow over time.
Is to set up an office of...
Basically it was called something like
civic engagement and social innovation.
And it was actually sat...
It was headed by someone
who actually was at UCI for a while.
He was originally a competitor
in the Global Social Venture
Competition at Berkeley.
He's connected to California.
Anyway, he worked very hard
within the administration
on things that are
social innovation funds.
Funds that can be used by
the federal government.
Small amounts of funds to promote
new policy approaches at
the state or local level.
And the other thing the
administration has done a lot of
is to try to improve
the efficiency of policy
by having things like
competitions for policy,
suggestions, so policy ideas.
And you sort of look at the results
and you kind of improve things.
They've brought in a lot
of private sector groups
to help improve things.
A very good example of this, by the way,
was when the healthcare,
the rollout of the system
encountered all of these flaws in design.
Basically, there were a lot of people
from the tech community who
just went in and helped.
They just said, "Okay,
we're gonna help out."
You know, things like Code for America.
There are important new
organizations that, oftentimes,
can work with the public sector.
That can be supported by the public sector
through a grant or
through a research project
to improve the way things are done.
And then, ideally, this is where
we're just seeing things happen.
An innovation in, say,
how you deliver healthcare
can actually start at a local level,
then be copied by a lot
of different communities.
And then scale up to the state level.
At every level, there is
federal money coming in,
because federal money is
a very important part of healthcare.
But the federal money is
being allocated in such a way
to allow for these experimental
innovative approaches.
- Let's talk about two problems
that are of a concern
to every progressive.
And the first is inequality,
which has really become a major topic.
And then, secondarily,
which is an aspect of that,
the plight of women and
their unequal situation.
Talk first about inequality.
I mean, what does the data show?
You've done a very good
job of explaining that
in some of your blog posts.
- Well, so, I think the most
important place to start
this discussion is to note that
the increase in income
and wealth inequality
is not unique to the United States.
It started about the same time,
which is probably in the late 1970s
and it's continued today,
in all of the developed...
Or I wouldn't say all.
But most of the developed
market economies.
In fact, I think it was all of them.
So, the first thing you say is
it's not unique to the United States.
You can say that, in the US,
two things are different.
One is that the top 1% has a larger share.
And that share has grown
most rapidly over time
compared to the other countries.
So, if you measure inequality that way,
the US clearly has the
most extreme inequality
because of the share of national income
or share of wealth that
goes to the top 1%.
But, if you measure
inequality by things like
the Gini coefficient, which
are meant to measure...
It's the overall measure of inequality
that's most commonly used.
The US actually looks not as bad as
countries like Germany
and the UK and Sweden.
But that's before the government
does anything to make it better.
So, the Gini coefficient might be
before the government does any tax policy
and any transfer policy
to help the disadvantaged
or the middle income.
What does income inequality look like?
Looks like it's getting worse every place.
The US doesn't look like it's
at the top, the worst, okay?
Where the US looks worse is
after the tax and transfer policy.
The other countries are doing a lot more
to bring the inequality in.
To reduce the inequality.
You can do that by childcare
policies, education policies,
health policies, income transfer policies.
By tax policy.
You can do it by a more
progressive tax code.
Actually, most countries
don't do it by the tax code
so much as by the transfer system,
because most of these other countries
have value added taxes,
which are, by themselves,
tend to be regressive.
So, the US does a lot less.
And that is a reflection
of our policy choices.
One might say, "Well,
alright, if all the countries
have encountered this problem
at around the same time,
what's driving the problem?"
And I am a structuralist
here in the sense of
thinking it's primarily technology,
which is taking out a lot of
middle income job opportunities
and pushing the opportunities
to the extremes.
Either low income job
opportunities or very high income.
You work with the technology.
The technology doesn't substitute for you.
You work with it.
It's your robot.
It's your technology.
And the technology in the
middle is taking out jobs.
And that leaves you with people
who are doing things that
require face to face engagement,
but they can be...
They can be rather low income jobs.
Healthcare orderlies might
be an example of that.
Very, very, very important.
Childcare givers.
Very, very, very, very important.
They don't earn much in the
way of income or benefits.
So, that's how I tend to see it.
There are others who really focus more on,
you know, the role of money in politics.
My colleague Bob Reich
would do that and say...
Look, I certainly think the erosion
of unions in the United States
has been a big contributor to...
Instead of holding against or pushing back
against these structural forces,
the ability of unions to push
that way has just collapsed.
I mean, 6% of the private
sector workforce is unionized.
Only 6%.
Who represents the worker here?
- In one of your columns,
you make the point,
which I would like for
you to go over here,
and that is that, traditionally,
productivity, rise in productivity,
was tied to the rise in income.
And, since the '70s, that has ceased.
And then all these factors
that you've talked about
play into that.
- Yeah, so, it's one of the big surprises.
And I think that any economist
who thinks about income inequality
sort of starts with that.
Because economic logic says that,
in general, labor markets are supposed to
reward people according
to their productivity.
So, if productivity is growing rapidly,
you would expect that
wages or compensation,
some measure of the
productivity of the workforce
would also be growing with
that productivity growth.
And, really, starting around 1980,
that gap between the rate
of growth of productivity
and the rate of growth
of worker compensation
started to open up.
It's a very large gap now.
As far as we know, it's the largest gap
that exists like that in
the developed countries.
Suggesting that there are
some things about, say,
things like labor markets
and unions, minimum wages.
So, again, I'm gonna say that,
in these other countries that do
a lot to compress income inequality,
it's not just their policies.
But they do...
Well, minimum wage is a policy.
They have much more generous
minimum wage policies.
So, the minimum wage is often
tied to the median wage.
If you put a serious
floor on the minimum wage,
you're gonna hold up the
entire wage distribution
to some extent.
We let the minimum wage just fall apart
in terms of real purchasing power.
And then unions have a much bigger role,
oftentimes, at the level of centralized
or nationwide wage agreements,
which are very, very important.
And we don't have those.
So, that gap might be largely explained by
or significantly explained
by the lack of institutions
to represent labor in what share
of those productivity
gains should go to workers.
- So, if this is a problem
of political economy,
it's the political that
becomes very important?
- Yes, yes.
Look, I would say that that gap,
part of that is also economic.
So, what you have going on here is that,
because of the technology,
a larger share of what
looks like wage income
ends up going to a very
small percentage of people.
Many of whom are not exactly workers,
'cause a lot of top
management is being paid
in the basis of shares
and restricted stock.
And, if you believe that those
shares and restricted stock,
over time, reflect the
growing productivity
and the growing revenues
that come from productivity,
it's being shared in a very unequal way.
So, I wanna say there're
both economic factors
behind the gap.
But certainly we, the politics or policy
is all about how we handle that gap.
What do we do about it if that's
the world that we live in?
If that's what the globalization
and technological change
are doing to middle income families?
And to lower income families.
What do we do about it?
And we're not doing nearly as much
as what some of our other
developed countries are doing.
And we don't seem to be moving
in the direction of doing more.
Indeed, the right wing of
the Republican Party...
And I would say even the Republican Party,
the median on the Hill,
really doesn't think we should
do as much as we're doing.
- Your journey as a policy person
and as an economist made you
sensitive to issues of gender.
And then, when you became dean
at the London School of Business,
you were sensitized to what was happening
to women graduates.
Let's talk about that.
'Cause you've been involved in shaping
what the World Economic Forum
calls a gender parity index.
Talk a little about that.
And what you're seeing that's disturbing.
- Okay, so, I think my
increasing engagement
in thinking about gender started to come,
really, when I came back to Berkeley.
Not because of what was going
on at Berkeley, by the way,
but because I became the
dean of a business school.
And then I became dean of a
business school and you...
I wanna say one thing.
I am a very progressive
Democrat, I would say.
But I've also really felt that.
Because of my role on boards
and because of the kind of academic work
I did on US competitiveness,
that I really understand
the importance of business.
And I want policy makers
to work well with business.
And I want really great educated leaders
to go into business.
So, I was very attracted to
being a dean of a business school.
I thought that was really a nice way to
combine my policy interest
with my pro-business,
pro-worker, how we're gonna get
this public-private
partnership for economics.
What I discovered early on was that
there weren't many female professors
and there weren't many students.
Whereas the students were in
medical school and law school
and public health, you had women enrolling
at about gender parity 50/50.
In business schools, way under 20.
You were lucky if you got to 20.
Women weren't applying in large numbers.
Then there was some evidence that
they were applying but
they weren't staying
in the business world
once they got the degree.
So, I just got interested.
And then I started to not so much here,
because, here, I was doing more
new economy stuff and technology
and just starting to think about gender.
But, when I got to London,
what I was asked initially to do
a report on diversity
and corporate governance.
Not to do the report, but
to chair a commission,
because it was a political hot potato.
And, since I was not a British citizen,
I could share this thing
totally objectively.
That was the view.
And I was on the boards of
several companies at that point.
So, I said, "Okay, I'll do that."
And I was struck by what we
discovered in that process
of the pipeline issue that I
talked about in the lecture.
The fact that you have
businesses, by the early 2000s,
who were really trying
hard to have gender parity
in their intake, in the
number of new employees.
But then it would all disappear
and you'd still see, at the
top levels, very few women.
Very few women on boards.
Very few women in top management.
Women disappearing in middle
management in large numbers.
So, what was going on?
Why is this happening?
And why is this happening for women
who are going to business school
and getting these degrees and then...
And so, that's how I became interested.
And then the World Economic
Forum approached me
and said would I be interested in working
on this new idea they had to
have one of their indices...
They do a lot of indices
on global competitiveness.
But they wanted to do an
index measuring gender parity.
So, over the time, they
developed a series of measures.
You can measure gender
parity on education,
on health, on politics,
and on economic opportunity
and advancement.
We put together the data.
There's always been a
really strong team on this
within the World Economic Forum.
And someone who's been
working on it consistently
the whole time who I have a
very close relationship with.
And we put together a report.
And it's basically come to be widely cited
and used by governments.
Used by businesses to think about
why are countries doing differently?
What could countries do better?
What could businesses
do better to actually
add to more economic
opportunity advancement?
To improve gender parity
on all these measures.
- And the bottom line is that women...
That there is progress,
but, in the final analysis,
not as much is happening
as should be happening.
- It's very slow.
So, look, the truth is...
First of all, I wanna say that
we don't have perfect measures.
In order to have a large
number of countries be covered,
we had to choose data that is
available for all countries.
So, with that being said,
what you find is that,
on education or on health,
even if you're a poor society,
most societies deliver
about the same degree
of educational attainment by gender.
Not all societies.
Clearly we can think of some that don't.
That the educational parity,
whether you measure it in
literacy or primary school
or secondary school and
now even tertiary school,
that, on education, parity is...
We are approaching parity.
The gender gap has been
dramatically reduced.
That stands in great contrast to
the disparities in what we call
economic opportunity and advancement.
And those would be measured by things like
the percentage of the
working age female population
that is working, their wage opportunities,
their advancement opportunities,
their percentage of high level jobs.
Those, on all of those indicators,
even most developed societies,
even the best performers in the world
haven't reduced the gender parity gap.
Now, they're quite low
in the Nordic Countries,
which are always top of the list here.
So, maybe they've eliminated 85%
of the gender gap in economics.
And then the final gap,
and this is the hardest one to measure,
which is why I talked about
the problems of the data,
is political representation.
Because women around the world tend to be,
if they're involved in politics,
more likely to be at the local level,
at the community level, at the town level,
at the city level, at the state level
than they are to be at the
federal or national level.
And so, we don't have
good indicators of that.
So, if you look at the national level,
things like ministerial positions
or presidential positions
or very high level
positions, all countries,
the biggest gap is the gender
gap in politics by far.
The progress.
We recently, in the last report,
we looked at the progress on
economic opportunity and advancement.
That's the one we looked at.
We said, "If the world
continues to make progress
at the current pace,
it will take 81 years to close that gap."
So, that's too long.
And I think that societies
have to work very hard
and organizations have to work very hard
to make more progress.
- I'm gonna recommend to our audience that
they watch your lecture, which is on UCTV,
where this interviewer appears.
And there are two very
interesting tables at the end
about how we can make change.
And you point out that this has to be done
at the individual level,
the cultural level,
the level of the company, and...
- The level of government.
- But I want to focus
onto another table also,
which compares the strengths of women
versus the strengths of men
and the stereotypes that go with them.
And so, I wanna ask you...
I wanna put all that together.
People are gonna go watch the
lecture and see the tables.
But it seems that two problems that
are really quite stand out.
One is the problem of having children,
rearing children, all of it is involved
in the woman's concern about
the family on the one hand.
Which suggests all sorts of policies.
And then the other is the extent to which
women are different than
men in a positive way.
In the sense that they have
different values and so on.
And, in both cases,
the company level and at the policy level,
this is not taken into account.
Adjustments are not made.
Is that a fair kind of superficial summary
of what you're saying there?
- Yeah, no, I actually hadn't
put it quite together that way,
but I think that I would agree
with everything you said.
So, on the issue of
families and childcare,
I think societies can do much more.
Here, I think, as I said,
on gender parity measures,
the Nordic Countries always top the list.
There's lots of things common to them.
But one of the key commonalities,
which other countries around the world now
are trying to learn from...
I know Japan is deeply involved
in studying the ways in which
Norway, Sweden, Iceland,
Finland support families.
Those are parental leave
policies, childcare policies,
early education policies,
doing everything society can
do to support the family.
Not the woman as opposed to the spouse.
The family is the thing to support.
The family and the children in the family.
And I think we can do much more.
You know, I also did say, in that lecture,
just last December, there was an article.
They did a survey of
Harvard Business School
men and women across generations.
From my generation down
to the Millennials.
And they asked questions about
expectations of men and women about
who would play the major role
of childcare in their family.
And both men and women
thought women would.
Still.
This is now.
This is right now.
So, there's no way.
It's not realistic.
This is where I'm an economist.
It's not realistic to say
you can simply have it all
and do it all.
Well, you can have it all and do it all
if you have a whole bunch of help.
But we can't assume that
the average woman is
going to be able to afford
a whole bunch of help.
Okay, that's just not it.
So, society is the source of the help.
Society should want to
help families so that
the talent of men and
women can be fully engaged
to improve the economy, improve society,
improve education.
So, that's my view on that.
And I think it is very, very important.
It's the first thing
countries can and should do
if their goal is to move
towards greater gender parity.
Then, on the issue of
business organizations
and gender differences, so, there is that.
I did put up in the lecture this one pager
which summarizes the work
of, say, the last decade
by a lot of economists,
social psychologists,
sociologists around the world
looking at differences
in behavior by gender.
So, looking at things like
differences in negotiating style
and styles of competition
and styles of working with
teams and styles of leadership.
What the results show are
things which I think many women,
and probably many men,
too, anecdotally think,
"Yeah, that's how it is."
But documenting them is
really, really important.
Because, let me just give you an example.
And it was highlighted by
what happened last fall
when the new CEO of Microsoft said,
when asked in a setting that
was a conference about women,
he was asked, "Well,
should women negotiate
for wage increases and promotions?"
He said, "I think that women
have some karma by not asking.
And then their talent will be discovered
and they will be promoted.
And they will get wage increases."
Well, if he had seen this research,
he would have known that
was just not the case.
That women don't tend to
negotiate for promotions
nearly as much as men.
They're not as confident as men.
They're not...
Even when they're as confident,
they're not as likely to go out and say,
"Hey, I'm really good.
Do something about this."
So, the whole human
resources of an organization
has to be designed
around these differences
if what you want to do is achieve
gender parity in outcomes.
You have to accept the
differences in behavior
and say "How do we reorganize
our human resources processes
to take account of these differences?"
By the way, he subsequently
said he was wrong.
And I said, "I just hope
his human resources person
knows this literature."
Because that's really what we have to do.
Organizations have to know
about these differences.
And, if they're committed
to developing the pipeline,
they are going to have
to make adjustments.
And many companies are
beginning to do just that.
- Well, on that note,
Laura, I wanna thank you
for taking the time to be on our program.
And I wanna, again, recommend
to our audience that
they watch your lecture as a
companion to this interview.
And I think the two together will
give an impressive sense of the ideas that
you've carried throughout your life.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much, Harry.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(peaceful music)